Je pense que gagner sa vie en tant qu'acteur est un
miracle en soi, mais pouvoir
faire les choses que j'ai eu la chance de
faire en plus, c'est plutôt au-delà de
moi, mais j'aurais été totalement heureux de
faire, vous savez, de faire  une vie en tant
qu'acteur
[Musique]
conducteur Adam conducteur escapade conducteur c'est
ce qui fait mal dommage n'est pas cette blague mais
c'est la vie
[Musique]
si vous connaissez quelqu'un dans un où vous êtes dans
la pièce ensemble dans sa seconde  la nature
et tout à coup ce n'est plus là ça
peut être une chose violente où tout à coup
vous intérieurement je veux dire pas physiquement
violent où vous perdez l'amour et vous
ne savez pas comment l'articuler
[Musique]
la vie est imprévisible et donc vous pouvez
avoir le monde avec les coups de poing et ne pas
forcer les choses à être comme vous le
souhaitez
[Music]
[Applaudissements]
vous essayez de rendre tout aussi personnel
que possible et vous savez ces choses
ont essayé  pour dire la vérité et le dire
et le penser,
vous êtes entouré de gens qui vous
soutiennent et qui sont là, puis
vous savez, espérons-le, quelque chose va arriver
[Musique]
ça va de mieux en
mieux je pense  qu'il est vous connaissez
le plus grand des plus grands
réalisateurs vivants et nous travaillons avec
lui et sur n'importe quoi - une
publicité Colgate je le fais avec
[Musique]
vous vous